hey what's up guys i'm tony gonzalez i'm
here with bleacher report and this is
build your squad all right I'm gonna
pick my all-time NFL squad well y'all
guys start with a quarterback so I'm
going to start with Joe Montana my guy
grew up in LA but watching all those
great 49er teams back in the 80s and
then playing for the Kansas City Chiefs
where he played for the last couple
years of his career I loved him threw a
perfect ball nice little spiral looked
very catchable and you want that as a
guy who catches the ball so I got to go
with him then from there we'll go with
the running backs I'm gonna take Barry
Sanders loved watching him if I was a
tecmo bowl guy too and when you got
Barry Sanders playing Tecmo Bowl you
couldn't be tackled he was a guy he's
good tackle and he's he's so little
he's a little guy and they couldn't get
ahold of him so I loved I loved watching
him play why well I'm I'm I'm gonna go
with him i'ma go Tony Gonzalez because I
think it'd be silly not to pick myself
and I owe it to myself yeah and and I'm
proud of myself
and I was pretty good for a while yeah
I'm gonna go Lawrence Taylor come on
Lawrence Taylor let's go out there like
a bunch of crazed dogs and have some fun
I'm saying that but Lawrence Taylor said
I didn't say that that guy was the man
sax against the run everything else and
then after that I'm taking Reggie White
Reggie way the most dominant defensive
player I've ever seen I had a chance to
actually play against him towards the
end of his career but just a guy in the
locker room - you need somebody in a
locker room to get everybody spirit
right before the game but then go out
there like a madman and and terrorized
opponent so that's a good squad right
there I think we can beat anybody I'd
love to see everybody else in squat
because I think that beats everybody
what's missing from this team is a ream
of what need a wide receiver cuz I don't
want to be just the main guy in and I'm
fast but I'm not that fat I need
somebody get over the top so if I'm
adding a guy it's gonna be
I probably I'm gonna go Randy Randy Moss
one-handed catches the the freak speed
just a four two guy I don't know how
fast he was but jumping up on everybody
with this guy throwing the ball Joe
Montana - - Randy Moss can't be beat if
you got him going over the top me
working the Middlebury centers out of
the backfield you can't stop that these
two they I don't care who you are you're
not blocking these two guys so lock
picks lock him in so this is my this is
my squad obviously don't Montana to me
the greatest of all time Barry Sanders
out of the backfield
Miah tight in work in the middle of the
field
red zone he's not on here but with Randy
Moss would be over the top and he'd be
the guy to put the speed take the top
off the defense but then on defense my
man Lawrence Taylor LT coming off the
edge and then Reggie White working the
mitt actually can come off the heads -
imagine those guys coming off the edge
collapsed in that pocket
it's a quarterbacks got no shot so the
squad right here I'm pretty I'm pretty
proud of this one all right guys I'm
Tony Gonzalez and I'm here with Sleep
Number sleep is something that I
prioritize I think everything begins
before you even think about nutrition or
working out you make sure you get a good
night's sleep it's it's totally
underestimated but it's something that
can actually change your life literally
will make you happier it will help you
make better decisions and will fire you
up you might not even need that that
second third cup of coffee if you can
get a good night's sleep so make sure
that you're out there getting your good
rest and this is build your squad